also wir gehen zu peter hell nach kiew
der dort den ganzen morgen unterwegs
erwerben um 5 uhr das erste mal mit ihm
gesprochen heute morgen aber in einem
luftschutzbunker hat dort stundenlang
ausgeharrt nicht in anderen mit
zivilisten steht jetzt auf der straße in
kiew peter was kannst du berichten wie
es die situation und denkt an das mikro
nannten uns zu halten damit man sich gut
verstehen kann
ok ich glaube jetzt ist es eigentlich
funktionieren wenn meine stimme noch
funktioniert also die situation ist im
moment etwas ruhiger geworden wir haben
hinter mir das ist der südwesten
aus der stadt raus haben wir gerade
schüsse gehört das deckt sich auch mit
den informationen
die wir von hinten bekommen haben
nämlich dass die verwaltung dringend den
bürgern geraten hat im südwesten nicht
mehr auf die straße zu gehen es soll
dort zu schießereien gekommen seien
gefechte mit maschinengewehrfeuer wurden
gehört wir haben von berichten gehört
dass bewohner weiße flaggen aus dem
fenster gehängt haben um zu
signalisieren dass sie sich ergeben dass
sie eben kein widerstand
leisten wollen und das ist genau das was
hier befürchtet wird dass eben die
bevölkerung die bewaffnet ist dass die
widerstand leisten wird und will vor
allen dingen zielinski und andere
politiker haben ja dazu aufgerufen
10.000 waffen wurden noch in den letzten
stunden an bürger und an
bataillon an bürger bataillone verteilt
also da ist der drang da ist der wille
die stadt die heimat zu verteidigen und
auch sehr groß und wir
haben gehört auch dass
auch das ist unbestätigt wir müssen uns
immer wieder sagen das können wir nicht
bestätigen dass die ukraine eine brücke
hinter uns selbst gesprengt haben soll
mehrere kilometer weiter um zu vermeiden
dass russen eben rüber kommen andere
sprechen davon dass die russen diese
brücke gesprengt hätten also das sind
alles unterschiedlich und sich
widersprechende teilweise information
und hinter mir das kann man auch mal
sehen wenn wir uns einmal umdrehen hier
rein da hinten in der stadt zentrum da
wo auch das
regierungsviertel ist da ist überhaupt
kein mensch mehr da ist im prinzip alles
komplett ausgestoßene ausgestorben also
da wird auch gewarnt auf die straße zu
gehen wir hatten heute morgen gehört
dass vier u-bahn-stationen weiter schon
zu kämpfen gekommen sein soll und dass
die kämpfe auch teilweise unterirdisch
geführt worden sind in diesen subway
station
also das sind alles beunruhigende
informationen wo unruhigen de
nachrichten die aber im prinzip alle auf
1 hindeuten dass es heute spätestens
heute abend wenn es dunkel ist dass wir
damit rechnen müssen dass russische
einheiten verstärkt in die stadt
einfallen einige straßen sind offenbar
schon gesperrt im südwesten werden von
russen vermutlich schon kontrolliert das
sind alles auch aussagen die haben wir
vom hörensagen wie können wir nicht
bestätigen aber es sieht so aus und das
deutet darauf hin dass heute abend
der ring sich enger ziehen würde
bombardements hat es bis jetzt keine
mehr gegeben es war relativ ruhig das
war es heute morgen der fall
beziehungsweise heute nacht ging es ja
an und im moment hat sich alles die lage
ein bisschen beruhigt meter das sind
ganz schreckliche prophezeiungen wir
sehen hinter dir eine
einkaufsstraße die geschäfte haben
natürlich alle zu zum teil sind sie
verbarrikadiert trotzdem muss man ja
davon ausgehen dass noch menschen in
ihren wohn nun sitzen zurzeit wie
versorgen die sich in dieser
notsituation
das ist eine gute frage also wir sehen
jetzt hier zum beispiel die beiden damen
jetzt gelang gehen die haben auch ihre
sachen
geschultert das sind so manche
spaziergänger die ja noch rumlaufen die
wohnen hier also das ist eigentlich
verwunderlich die meisten sind geflohen
wir schon richtig gesagt habe über fünf
millionen flüchtlinge werden ja erwartet
eigentlich aber die meisten sind in
ihren wohnungen sie sitzen am fernseher
sitzen am radio und sie hoffen natürlich
dass eben dieser albtraum schnell hier
durchzieht ohne dass es zu diesem
befürchteten straßenkämpfen kommen soll
denn wenn das stattfindet und wenn auch
die ganzen gerüchte stattfinden dass zum
beispiel das wird davon gesprochen dass
es russische greift rupps geben soll die
junge männer von den straßen holen
das lager errichtet worden sind das sind
alles informationen die sind nicht
bestätigt aber sie können seien sie
können natürlich zu treffen aber sie die
natürlich nicht so zur zur optimierung
der stimmung eigentlich also hier ist
eine ganz bedrückte untergangsstimmung
muss man sagen und
uns eingeschlossen wir haben alle
natürlich angst was passiert oder es
gibt ein paar meldungen geht
zwischenzeitlich werden wir sprechen
hereinkommen bleibt bitte bei uns zum
einen das ist natürlich wichtig für alle
die familie jetzt haben in ukraine wir
haben vorhin mit einer dolmetscherin
gesprochen aus dresden auch es ist nur
eine kleinigkeit aber immerhin die
telekom macht anrufe und sms in die
ukraine jetzt kostenfrei und auch die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
hat sich inzwischen zu wort gemeldet
verurteilte den russischen angriffs aufs
schärfste sie sagt wörtlich diese
angriffskrieg russlands markiert eine
tiefgreifende zäsur in der geschichte
europas nach dem ende des kalten krieges
kalten krieges für diesen eklatanten
bruch des völkerrechts gibt es keinerlei
rechtfertigung ich verurteile ihn auf
das schärfste kommt so was an hört da
irgendjemand noch auf solche sachen das
sind alles nebensächlichkeiten in diesem
in kiew in der ukraine
ich glaube das sind alles ja
nebenkriegsschauplätze das interessiert
keinen menschen mehr wenn ich mal das so
salopp sagen darf ich glaube diese leute
haben hier ganz andere sorgen sie sind
längst haben sie die hoffnung aufgegeben
dass sie richtig vom westen unterstützt
werden von der nato von der eu außer mit
den deutschen helm oder mit anderen
dingen also da hat man schon längst die
die das interesse auch verloren also man
richtet sich jetzt ganz klar oder guckt
auf sich selbst schaut dass man hier die
tage die nächsten wochen vernünftig oder
überlebt vor allen dingen und das
geplänkel sag ich mal so was da jetzt
aus der eu kommt oder von anderen
politikern das kommt hier weder an und
jeder weiß ist nutzt ja auch nix ist ist
ja totaler es ist ja faktisch totaler
quatsch man muss sich vorstellen draußen
stehen mehrere kilometer paar kilometer
stehen russische panzer einheiten die in
die nächsten stunden durchbrechen werden
dass da interessiert es keinen menschen
mehr bei allem respekt was dann eine
frau
bundeskanzler sagt und das sind alles
worte das ist natürlich versucht der
versuch eine prise krisendiplomatie noch
mal ein bisschen nach vorne zu bringen
das ist auch verständlich das ist auch
richtig aber das kind ist in den brunnen
gefallen da hätten die dinge im prinzip
schon früher praktiziert werden müssen
da wäre hätte man früher schon viel
wesentlich aggressiver und bestimmter
wladimir putin gegenübertreten müssen
was jetzt passiert ist einfach beten
beten beten wir müssen gucken oder hier
die stadt muss gucken und die ganze
ukraine muss gucken wie sie jetzt die
nächsten tage über steht da kann man nur
hoffen dass das halbwegs
normal oder abläuft ohne zu viele
verletzte und dann was die leute
natürlich meistens beschäftigt und das
ist die wesentliche frage eigentlich
hier in dieser stadt und auch in diesem
land was passiert nachdem die russen
hier drin gewesen sind das heißt welche
regierung wird hier eingesetzt was für
eine regierungsform kommt bei mir denn
keiner glaubt er ernsthaft an dem sieg
hier der ukraine gegen diese welt macht
also das sind alles fragen bekommen sie
wieder ein diktator vorgesetzte
janukowitsch seiner zeit
der das volk malträtiert also das sind
die größten ängste also für die menschen
die hier leben ist der drops wenn es mal
salopp sagen darf längst gelutscht die
möchten über leben und sie hoffen hoffen
hoffen dass sie eine halbwegs moderat
regierung kriegen wir auch immer aber
daran glaubt natürlich kein mensch geht
das angesprochen die frage ist natürlich
was was wird mit dieser stadt passiert
einen eine stadt die auch für viele
touristen auch hier aus deutschland ein
sehr schönes reiseziel einmal war es
gibt tolle geschäfte das ist eine
moderne
freundliche stadt gewesen wo man gerne
hin gefahren ist für den wochenendtrip
um urlaub dort zu machen das wird nie
wieder so sein oder
auch das will ich nicht sagen ich will
jetzt auch nicht so schwarz mal nur alle
zeichen stehen jetzt natürlich nicht auf
sonnenschein das ist ja klar wenn denn
so die befürchtungen eintreten was ich
jetzt gerade gesagt habe dass eben eine
regierungsfreundliche russisch
regierungsfreundliche diktatur diktatur
ja wahrscheinlich auch regierung hier
eingesetzt wird
wovon ausgehen kann das ist ja auch sinn
und zweck der übung von wladimir putin
mir dann kann man davon ausgehen das ist
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so frei ist
wie es einmal war dieses fröhliche bunte
tf mit seinen jungen menschen mit seinen
tollen prachtboulevards mit seiner
unglaublichen kultur die hier ist also
das sind sachen die werden sich
vermutlich ändern und die andere frage
ist was passiert auch mit den ganzen
parlamentariern mit den demokratisch
gewählten abgeordneten die so hört man
ja auch auf listen stehen sollen von den
russen flüchten die haben sie überhaupt
noch eine eine parlamentarische struktur
hier zu erwarten die ukraine für die
nächste zukunft was wird aus
vernünftigen wahlen wird überhaupt noch
mal richtig gewählt also das sind alles
fragen die sie stellen sich erst danach
erst jetzt geht es step by step 'als
wartet man erst mal ab was passiert wenn
die russen hier drin waren und dann
wird wahrscheinlich der kuchen
aufgeteilt und dann kommt noch einmal
das große katzenjammer denn dann wird
die ukraine anders aussehen als sie
jetzt aussieht
aus kiew anstatt die gerade bei vielen
deutschen jugendlichen und jungen
menschen auch sehr beliebt ist eine sehr
populäre stadt nur noch ganz kurz diese
meldung dazu danke peter